conspiracy theories flourish when people  lose trust in their political  institutions as we are seeing today but  the collapse and credibility of our  institutions is not the fault of  conservatives it is the fault of the  liberals who have controlled those  institutions for decades and run them  into the ground  to be a conspiracy theorist during times  of political order and transparency is  kooky and ridiculous  but to be a conspiracy theorist  during times of profuse conspiracy is  rational and prudent  in an age such as ours the difference  between a conspiracy theory and the  truth is often not the difference  between delusion and reality  as our liberal ruling class has shown so  clearly over the past few years in an  age such as ours the real difference  between a conspiracy theory and the  truth is about three to six months